Speaker 1: One of the completely baseless claims
that Republicans are making in response to the
hammer attack on Nancy Pelosi's husband, Paul
Pelosi, is that this is all the fault of Democrats
defunding the police and that prosecutors are
too lax and that Democrat cities, so-called, are
extraordinarily dangerous. This is the line that
they're coming up with. The truth is that this was
a right winger who didn't like Nancy Pelosi and
wanted to break her kneecaps so she would have
to be wheeled into the House of Representatives to
send a message to other Democrats. You better be
careful. Your consequences have actions.
Here is Donald Trump's one time acting
attorney general assistant Matt Whitaker. You guys
remember this guy? He said, we have to look at the
bigger picture. How convenient. Forget about the
fact that David the poppy or the pape was a right
winger. Anti-Vaxx like Tim Poole and anti-Semitic.
All this difference. Forget about that.
It's the bigger picture of
democrat crime in Democrat cities.
Speaker 3: Your reaction to
what took place? Paul Pelosi.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Well, obviously, it's a
as reported, it's a horrific, you know,
invasion of his home and and an assault
on him. And, you know, political violence
should never and does not have a place in our
society. We have to look at a bigger picture,
Maria, and that is is that San Francisco is is
crime riddled. And a lot of it is due to the
lax policies of the local prosecutor. And when you
when you take that context, it's going to be very
interesting how this individual who is charged
with some serious crimes, whether he gets the same
treatment as of a lot of the violent criminals.
Speaker 1: Right. The problem is they're going
to treat him more roughly than the other
Antifa, BLM, whatever, because this guy is
maybe a right winger, but maybe not understand
that this analysis is bogus. Nancy Pelosi and
her husband weren't the victims of a random
home invasion related to the broader crime
situation in San Francisco. They were targeted
by a right winger for their political views,
the lax prosecution, whether you believe that's
what is taking place in San Francisco or not,
the other one is the defunding of police,
which hasn't happened. This is a specifically
targeted crime and this is a way of them trying to
figure out how do we blame attacks on Democrats,
on Democrats themselves and understand the
incredible difference between these two political
groups. You don't see Democratic candidates with
assault rifles in their campaign ads. You just
don't see it. You don't see Democratic campaign
ads with targets on Republicans. The way dating
back to Sarah Palin and much more recently
we have seen Republicans do. And meanwhile,
I think it's important to mention crime isn't
even actually up in San Francisco. I know that
they love to talk about this. Just look up violent
crime and property crime and you will see that
it's just it's just not up. The numbers are very
steady and even a little bit lower than they were
five years ago. There has been no defunding of
the police in San Francisco. Violent crime is
just not up. And so even the premises on which
some of these claims are based are completely
and totally untrue. Make sure that if you watch
our clips on YouTube, you're not just watching
the clips. Make sure you hit that subscribe
button. It is free every time you hit that
subscribe button. Alex Jones grimaces.
Speaker 3: Thank your lucky stars every
day. You're not David.
Speaker 1: Pakman. Yeah,
there's nearly 3 million of you that regularly
watch our videos but are not subscribed. Let's
get to 2 million folks. Hit that subscribe button.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
Remember that the David Pakman show is an
audience supported program you can sign up at,
join Pacman Dotcom, get the daily bonus show
just for members. Get the daily podcast in audio
or video form with no commercials five or 6 hours
before everybody else gets it and get the invites
to the members only town halls
with me by simply signing up at
join pacman dot com. You can use
the coupon code big voting 22.